covid is a is in general uh
actually a huge world acceleration lab
uh for processes that meant to take
years and now
actually they're happening in weeks or
even months so it's an
acceleration of acceleration welcome to
20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford we're in the world of cyber
security and i'm honored to have moshe
lipscore
svp global product development at
imperva with us
moshe is the svp of global product
development and israel general manager
at imperva
imperva is recognized by industry
analysts as a cyber security leader
moshe joined in perva in 2018 as data
security vice president engineering
and has held a variety of leadership
roles prior to joining imperva moshe was
vice president engineering at celebrity
and held executive positions at polycom
moshe earned bachelor's degree in
computer science from borough line
university an executive mba from the
hebrew university in jerusalem
moshe lipscore thank you for joining me
on 20 minute leaders how are you today
i'm okay thank you for inviting me it's
a pleasure
i'm honored to have you here i'm honored
to have
an opportunity to talk to you about
about your journey
and in particularly cyber security and
you know all the way from celebrate to
imperva today
today being the general manager and
senior vice president of global product
development
i'm going to talk to you about you know
innovation and a big corporate i want to
talk to you about
um you know innovation at scale when
you're managing 500 people here in
israel but you know 1400 people
worldwide but even before that i want to
talk about cyber security
you know something that we in israel
understand
particularly through innovation through
a necessity but but i'd love to first
start you know high level
what is it why is it important and
what's happened what's been happening
through kovid
moshe take me all the way back to your
infantry days in the army
you don't come from a cyber security
background how do you get into
this a crazy crazy world
okay so you know in the israeli cyber
arena
if you don't come from one of the elite
tech
units you don't count right
so i did not came from these elite tech
units but i did came from one of these
the elite combat units so
uh like unlike my uh colleagues
in the i'm i was in the infantry
special forces and i assume that my
background
special forces plus commanding brought
me to the position where
my managerial and leadership type of
capabilities
are reflected very well in my day-to-day
job
so this is the background of uh
how how it had come come about and
so you you go into the world of cyber
security and
a little bit overview so i'll give a
i'll give a background
about about imperva and then and and
then
talk about cyber in the covered of
course um
so impervious is one of the biggest
cyber
cyber security players in the world as
you i assume know
our product uh portfolios com the
combination of
application security and data security
where the application security uh
products around
web application firewall ddos
distribution denial of service
bot protection routes etc and the
data security products are around a
breach
data breach prevention which we see a
lot
over the last month and year
and in perfect footprint in the club
is in the cloud in the on-prem and
hybrid environments
all over and the competitive evaluation
is
in terms of size is two plus billion and
the annual revenue is hundreds of a
million so
we're big in in terms of company size
we're around
1400 employees over the globe and 500 in
r d
which are distributed in 10 sites around
the globe israel north america and emea
so going to the cyber trends in the
covet so
covid is in general uh
actually a huge world acceleration lab
and for processes that meant to take
years and now
actually they're happening in weeks or
even months so it's an
acceleration of acceleration so i'll
give you an example
um a very simple one the move from
physical to virtual
it can be related to work environments
the the move to work remotely from home
without covey that it would have taken
years right and now uh
one no one is gonna work
100 percent in a classic pre-covered
office
never we're moving to a homophobe in a
hybrid environment
never right so in a more advanced
example
is is the move from on-premises to the
cloud
for companies that are not native born
in the cloud
you can see a good example in the in
some
market segments such as a financial
organizations banks insurance etc
which would have been taken then years
to transform the organizational workload
to the cloud from data centers but
and they defined such strategy for them
but
it would have taken years and now it's
taking
months is even more even less even weeks
right everyone is blowing into the cloud
right because no physical footprint for
these
for these companies so as a result the
speed to the cloud
or to the virtual domain it actually
it creates tons of cyber
opportunities for hackers
actually cyber exploits that
that they can take advantage of and this
is a very
crazy world that we're entering into and
i
am i'm not sure that the the population
understands
what's happening at the moment in the
cyber arena
give me a round down so there
yeah so it's
there there is clearly clearly a
trajectory of attackers
which are increasing dramatically over
so uh the last call of the year so a
very simple example
is the last attack of the supply chain
of firearm
fire eye via solid winds are you
familiar with that
that actually a fire eye
the company that is supplying for north
america multiple companies
including the dod of america right and
wins and this
was in the press it's the public yep and
actually solar winds
which provided the product which is
called orion
was hacked so actually follow with was
hacked
in fire r r i that is
distributed in multiple companies in in
in north america so this is a very
sophisticated complex attack that took a
place
uh and it by the way at that sense
to be part of the cyber world where when
we i'm
on the side or we are in the side of the
good guys
is something very meaningful for for me
in person
but anyhow bottom line the trend of
acceleration
to the cloud is creating opportunities
to uh to attackers
and decide and for the cyber vendors to
bridge
uh these gaps um a a very good effect
that can validate my statement is the
the the fact that the cyber industry
growth
globally year over year was double digit
in 2020
which means that that there is
a war there outside and there are all
these companies that are trying to
bridge the gaps of this
offense defense play right right
so this is not the main situation that
we were seeing
and companies like imperva or others are
trying to to help as much as they can
organizations to secure the world so one
thing that i wanted to
to pick your brain on er monsieur is
i've been hearing
you know some people not a lot but some
people that are that are saying you know
no cyber security is a bubble you know
it's it's overpriced and you have
companies that
you know they're pretty much doing the
same thing at crazy valuations
and and and that it there you know the
market is not is not really there and if
it is there it's not going to be there
in five to ten years i personally don't
agree with that opinion i think that i'm
on
pretty much the opposite spectrum in
this cat and mouse game but i'd love to
hear your take
on on where are we actually headed in
terms of the cyber security market
in terms of how technology is advancing
and are we going to keep seeing
a lot of these fragmented solutions do
you expect we're going to be converging
to to some market leaders that are going
to dominate the market
how do you see the cyber security world
moving forward
um so you talked about the
the move from from cyber security to big
data
and it's very related in machine
learning and artificial intelligence
so actually the the trends in the world
is moving to
big data and all this information
collection
is creating a spectrum where
data is enabling artificial intelligence
for a for cyber
security uh vendors for example
a bot protection let's let's take our
broad protection
product or or things that are related to
data you you see attack an automation
attack
that someone is trying to to scrap your
website or
scrap one of the biggest websites in the
world by automation bot attacks
now the way we can address this attack
or mitigate the problem
is by collecting all these data creating
artificial intelligence on top of that
and analytics
and react as
a response or as a mitigation so so the
way
we can improve ourselves is by big data
in
in addition to that the the fact that
data is gold today
and the main assets of organizations are
around
uh assets around data so
all these data breaches breaches are are
are the way for hackers to create
ransomware
and operations and
they take a customer data so
you need to protect that right and even
even if those the hackers are
and these hackers are not personally
private people they're they're organized
in organizations
which they're trying to get the data not
only from
ransomware from but for um to
actually run some algorithms from
themselves
on top of this data so data is king and
data
is the main um trajectory
for cyber security in the future so what
i'm hearing from you
is that isn't you know looking at data
as you know the thing to protect
and in that same game it is the thing to
steal
so you know it's not you know it's not
you know bank robber it's not going in
and physically taking things it's not
stealing necessarily even the technology
it's stealing you know data and in that
regard as we see that you know data is
exploding
and and obviously we've seen since 2016
the numerous case studies on
on how our data is being stored uh you
know immensely throughout throughout all
these fragmented companies then what i'm
hearing from you really is that you know
we're just
starting we're just scratching the
surface of this big
cannon mouse game absolutely
well so it's something both exciting
it's uh it's very exciting it's a
beginning of a new era
which we will see more
machine learning more artificial
intelligence getting into this
cyber space and
and it looks like the sky is the limit
for both sides for the attackers and the
defenders right right but it's but it's
fascinating and and it's um something
that i didn't
i didn't have the opportunity so far to
be part of
uh in in such scales
and i think that moshe this is a perfect
segue to the you know just as
just a meaningful question you know in
this cat and mouse game that we're
describing here and so far we've
really talked about you know the
defensive side and how you know covet
has accelerated things and how data is
is taking over the world software is
eating the world
through the words of the wise a and mark
andreessen and
and with that we talk about you know
this this marvelous cat and mouse game
between the
the red team and the blue team empire
obviously the blue team
but really you exist because there is a
phenomenal red team
that inevitably is going to be one step
ahead because
they are the ones that are you know
breaking the rules and then you're
building on top of that hopefully you
know obviously there are efforts to to
mitigate that but but that is the nature
of the game
and and in order to keep up in order to
win
you need to innovate constantly with
1400 people with 500 in r d
so talk to me a little bit about you
know organization corporate innovation
and how you know as a senior vice
president and
general manager of the israeli branch
how do you lead
you know hundreds of people through this
mission of innovation
okay so this is a huge challenge by the
way it's not a
an easy one but the way to address this
huge challenge is by creating a value
yeah value to to the organization
from my perspective in four dimensions
it's
a double downing on operational
it's uh emphasizing on platform play
then
innovation and then the personal
leadership
touch so i'll try to uh to
pinpoint and to drill down to each one
of them
so the operational side the way to
operate
in this such of scale is actually to
transform
from a giant carrier to speed boats so
instead of maintaining one big
organization of
500 and manage all these dependent
dependencies at once what i'm trying to
do or we are trying to do
is we're trying to treat it in a way you
treat a complex problem so how do you
actually treat complex problems you need
to break it to small
manageable sub challenges and actually
you need to create for example 25
groups of 20 people instead of one per
500 right
so first thing we you need to do is to
decouple the dependencies between all
these speed boats
once you define what are the speed boats
in order to provide a level of autonomy
each one needs
this is a key right and and then you
you actually become as a leader uh
enabler of
for teams to for successful delivers
and the challenge is to deliver all
these products in parallel
and keep the core expertise
simultaneously
with the ability to leverage the
competence of a big
organization because if you decoupled to
25 speed votes so what's like
25 startups so where is the leverage
between them
and how do you actually use the
competence of the big
organization so the answer for that is
by we're working an imperative in the
engineering in a matrix
which we call that guilds and gangs or
guilds and squads it's not new
spotify is working like that wix is
working like that multiple
cost companies guilds are responsible
expertise
and gangs or squads are responsible for
the delivering the products
and the terms of in terms of our worlds
and responsibilities
the professional guilds are responsible
for the how and the
delivery gangs are responsible for the
why what and when
and after the creation of this type of
organization you can emphasize
within these groups to the market
business and the actual value prop
to the customers so you need to create a
the structure
enable it and be an enabler for the for
the structure and then
push the speed votes to success and to
deliver this
value proposition to the customers so
you need to the question is now how
do you leverage between all these speed
votes the
core capabilities of the entire
organization so the answer
right for that is then the second
dimension which is platform play
platform play from my perspective is you
develop once you leverage and reuse
multiple times so you need to transfer
the dna and culture of the organization
in a way those teams are not reinventing
the wheels again and again it's not
25 groups for for the example
that are reinventing the wheels in a
silo they need to have
a lab collaboration between them and
actually
this platform plays creating a growth
engine for the entire organization so
that's how you can leverage the
competence and competence of a big
organization
and and once you have this structure and
the platform play
you need in parallel to create this
innovation
so how do you innovate in that area
because this is the question i'm trying
to
answer a short a question in a very long
way but this i i think it's thorough
enough to provide the answer
so on top of the operational efficiency
aka speedboats
and the platform play that are
leveraging the core capabilities that i
spoke
you need to innovate by incubation of
ideas
that can market disrupt the market
because otherwise
somehow someone else will do it instead
of you so
if we we will not innovate enough it
will be
we we will become a stagnate stagnated
organization and
and we will not grow so we created on
top of that or aside of that in
incubation we call it
incubation acceleration whatever but the
idea here is to
have another startup and this is a very
siloed startup which is running
uh like health analyzing analyzing the
market
understanding the market trends think
like a startup
talk like a startup detached from the
mothership
and actually trying to create the
collaboration of the
all the brains that we can get into and
we have
lots of brains so this innovation
incubation is actually
helping us so you need to strike the
organization and
and run it run the operation and create
a side kick of
innovation incubation organization and
and the last they mentioned
is related to and this is not related to
the question of innovation but it's
related to
leadership and big organizations so i
believe in
a leadership by keeping the human
personal touch
and i'm investing a lot of my time
in one-on-ones i i learned it from the
army
from the idf but if you create this
personal touch
360 with all people off the side and
below
and below i i don't mean your only your
subordinates but skip level of
n minus 1 and minus 2
as much as you can and create this
personal connection you can actually
influence the organization to do
all this operation that i uh described
so it's a big challenge but it's doable
and
and it sounds like a it sounds like a
very fun and phenomenal challenge that
and i appreciate sharing all the
insights and i think that uh
corporate innovation is something that
i've been extremely curious about as
i've
and i've gotten to talk to to some
really fantastic people working
for these great companies and then the
question stems okay well in an emerging
world where you have you know so many
different startups trying to solve so
many of the different problems that also
corporates are solving
what we know what what are the pros and
cons
and who has the competitive advantage
and until now you know people are saying
that yes obviously a small startup
a squad of you know great engineers has
an advantage over a big corporate that
is trying to you know
to to to to walk while the startup is
running but
but now you have this wave of
understanding that actually you can you
can still run in
a big company you can still innovate and
still run moshe thank you so much for
your time and for
spending these 20 minutes with me i
really appreciate it the last question
and the most important one
is three words that you would use to
describe yourself
uh okay so actually i put it
under my signature it's think big
start small and move fast i love it
thank you very very much best of luck
with imperva it was wonderful
thank you for being the good guys and
and i
can't wait to keep in touch